[Music]
in this lecture we discussed the
conquests of Alexander the Great and
Alexander's impact on the Jews and later
Jewish tradition we end by exploring
possible parallels between later
traditions surrounding Alexander and
Jesus our story starts in the fourth
century BC when Alexander's father
philip ii of macedon united all of
greece under his rule after philip ii
was assassinated in 336 BC Alexander at
the age of eighteen succeeded him to the
throne and became King of Macedonia and
ruler of Greece two years later in 334
BC Alexander launched an invasion of the
Persian Empire
remember that at this point the Persian
Empire bordered on Greece going right up
to the area of Macedonia Alexander
crossed the Hellespont with his
Macedonian troops and landed on Persian
soil near ancient Troy
over the course of the next few years
Alexander eventually fought and won
three major battles against the Persian
King Darius the third after the last
battle in 331 BC Darius's own men killed
him and that cleared the way for
Alexander to become ruler of all of the
lands of Persia
however this was not the end of
Alexander's conquests
he continued to push eastwards with his
troops into lands that had not been
subject previously to the Persians
including bacteria and sogdiana modern
Afghanistan and across the Indus River
Valley into India
once Alexander had conquered all of
these lands he never returned to his
native Greece instead he set up court in
Babylon where he died in the year 323 BC
now during the course of Alexander's
conquests and his march through the
lands of the Persian Empire he came
through Palestine through the area of of
the Land of Israel this happened in the
year 332 BC when Alexander detoured
south in order to reach Egypt
while in Egypt Alexander did a couple of
very important things that will be
important for his later tradition number
one he founded a new city on the coast
which he named after himself
he called it Alexandria number two he
visited an irregular shrine dedicated to
the god Zeus Amman in an oasis called C
WA which was out in the desert and the
importance of this visit is that when
Alexander approached the oculars shrine
he was greeted by the local priests as
if he was a God
now in order to reach Egypt Alexander
passed through Palestine because of
course he was coming from the north and
as he passed through Palestine then the
country including the Jews came under
Alexander's rule and the Jews or Judeans
submitted peacefully to Alexander as he
marched through
Greek historians do not mention
Jerusalem or the Jews in connection with
Alexander's conquests which is actually
not surprising because of course Judea
was the home of an obscure people an
insignificant tribe the Jews and in fact
no contemporary Jewish sources refer to
Alexander either in other words we do
not have any ancient Greek sources or
contemporary Jewish sources that talk
about Alexander the Great's
conquest of Judea
but after Alexander died Jewish sources
began to develop about a supposed visit
by Alexander to Judea and Jerusalem and
we're going to talk about these
now the silence of contemporary sources
about a visit by Alexander to Jerusalem
or in Judea doesn't mean that Alexander
did not visit Jerusalem or Judea but but
probably he did not in fact and the
reason is that he wouldn't have any
reason to in order to go from north from
the area of Syria down to Egypt
Alexander would have gone along the
coast and our sources in fact indicate
that that is the road that he took the
coastal road always being the easiest
way to go from north to south through
the country there's no there's no reason
that Alexander would have taken the
hilly mountainous roads in the interior
of the country which would have gone by
way of Judea and Jerusalem so in fact
it's it's pretty likely that Alexander
never went through to rissalah and Judea
as he went to Egypt in 332 BC
so Alexander passes through the country
through Palestine in 332 BC on his way
to Egypt and then after visiting Egypt
continues on his conquest through the
West the rest of the Persian Empire what
happened when Alexander passed through
in 332 is that he had to now make
arrangements to administer the country
to govern the country and it's
interesting that Alexander chose to
accept and left intact the religious and
political privileges that the Jews had
enjoyed under the Persians so basically
what he did is he left the governing
system intact and replaced the Persian
officials and administrators with his
own men
now in the centuries after the death of
Alexander when Alexander became the
Great the Jews sought to associate
themselves with Alexander and his
greatness and it's in these centuries
that stories and legends began to
circulate among the Jews about a visit
by Alexander to Jerusalem and Judea and
other traditions began to develop and
circulate as well perhaps the best known
of these is Daniels vision of the RAM
and the he-goat which is in the Book of
Daniel chapter 8 verses 1 through 27 and
here is what this passage the relevant
part of this passage reads in the third
year of the reign of King Belshazzar a
vision appeared to me Daniel of the same
nature as that which had previously
appeared to me I raised my eyes and
looked and lo standing in front of the
stream there was a ram with two horns
I saw the RAM budding westward northward
and southward none of the beasts could
stand before him nor could anyone rescue
from his power he did as he pleased and
accomplished great exploits as I was
considering the matter lo a he-goat from
the west advanced over the whole face of
the earth and without touching the earth
and the goat had a conspicuous horn
between his eyes and he smote the RAM
and broke his two horns and as the RAM
had no power to stand before him he cast
him down to the ground and trampled upon
him there being none to rescue the RAM
from his power
behold I Gabriel and making known to you
what shall be at the end of the time of
Wrath for the vision relates to the
appointed end of all the RAM which you
saw with the two horns is the king of
media and Persia the he-goat is the king
of Greece so in this passage
Daniel is shown a vision which involves
this this RAM and a he-goat
and the passage ends by explicitly
identifying the RAM which has two
with the king of media and Persia hence
the two horns and the he-goat
coming from the West is Alexander the
Great who conquers the RAM who conquers
the Persian Empire and this is a a
vision which relates to the coming end
of days something that we'll be talking
about more so notice how this story
embeds Alexander in Jewish expectations
about the end of days now we have
another famous story involving the Jews
and Alexander this is a story which is
preserved by the ancient Jewish
historian Flavius Josephus Josephus
tells this story which is highly legend
legendary and according to the story
Alexander was greeted by the high priest
the Jewish High Priest jdoah who
presented Alexander with the Jewish
community's capitulation and then
Alexander offered a sacrifice in the
Jerusalem Temple and here is what the
relevant part of this passage says
now Alexander when he had taken Gaza
made haste to go up to Jerusalem
parenthetically notice Alexander's on
the coast he's at Gaza right which is on
the way to Egypt so that's exactly where
you would expect him but according to
this legend Alexander now sort of takes
a detour to go to Jerusalem okay moving
on with the story
jdoah the high priest when he heard that
was an agony and terror not knowing how
he could meet the Macedonians when he
understood that Alexander was not far
from the city he went out in procession
with the priests and the multitude of
the citizens the procession was
venerable and the manner of it different
from other nations for Alexander when he
saw the multitude at a distance in white
garments while the priest stood clothed
with fine linen and the high priest and
purple and scarlet clothing with the
metre on his head with a golden plate on
which the name of God was engraved he
approached by himself and bowed down
before the name of God and first saluted
the high priest now the point of this
story is pretty obvious to show that not
only did Alexander detour in order to
meet with the Jews and go to Jerusalem
but that when he saw the appearance of
the high priest and the other priests
and the name of God he was so odd that
he bowed down in other words Alexander
according to this legend recognized the
greatness of the God of Israel
so these are the sorts of stories and
legends that began to circulate about
Alexander and his conquests after the
time of Alexander among the Jews what
happens with the Samaritans under
Alexander is an interesting contrast
with the case of the Jews the Jews of
course submitted peacefully to Alexander
but this was not what happened with the
Samaritans now at first the Samaritan
governor saw and balot the third in fact
supported Alexander something that we
have talked about and was even given
permission by Alexander to build the
Samaritan temple on Mount Gerizim so
basically the the governor the Persian
governor of the district of Samaria the
medina of Samaria defected over to
Alexander's side very early on and in
exchange was given permission by
Alexander to build a samaritan temple on
Mount Gerizim
however after Samba lot de third died
the Samaritans for reasons that are not
clear rebelled against Alexander and
burned alive his governor in punishment
Alexander destroyed the city of Samaria
which of course had been the capital
city of this district going all the way
back to the time of the biblical Kingdom
of Israel and banished the Samaritans
from the city and the Samaritans now
went to live at Shechem the biblical
city of Shechem our modern Nablus at the
foot of Mount Gerizim
at the foot of their sacred mountain and
from this point on the district of
Samaria had two major urban but very
different urban centres and it located
very close to each other
number one the Samaritan or Yahweh sztyc
population that was concentrated in the
area of Mount Gerizim and Shechem and
number two the city of Samaria which now
became a Greek city because Alexander
settled their macedonian military
veterans and these two urban centers
Shechem or Nablus and the city of
Samaria are located only about five
miles apart from each other
so Alexander died at a young age in 323
BC and his death plunged his empire into
a civil war that lasted for the next 20
years and during the course of this long
period of Civil War Alexander's mother
his three wives and his his offspring
were all killed and eventually
Alexander's Empire was divided up among
various generals for our purposes the
two most important generals are Seleucus
Salukis got most of Asia Minor Syria and
Mesopotamia very large chunk of land and
this kingdom then which we know is the
Seleucid kingdom was ruled by Seleucus
as successors who are called the
Seleucids the other general who's
important for us is Ptolemy who got
Egypt and his kingdom the Ptolemaic
Kingdom was ruled by Ptolemy successors
who were called the ptolemies and what's
important to note here is that Palestine
therefore was located right smack dab
between the Seleucids to the north and
the ptolemies to the south and therefore
was a bone of contention between them
sort of going back and forth
during most of the third century BC
Palestine was under the rule of the
Ptolemies and during most of the second
century BC Palestine was under the rule
of the Seleucids
now one of the challenges that
Alexander's successors faced was
legitimizing themselves as the heirs of
Alexander in the eyes of their
populations and the problem here is that
none of Alexander's successors none of
these generals were actually related to
Alexander and in antiquity the law of
succession was usually dynastic so you
succeeded somebody who was a member of
your family but none of Alexander's
successors were related to Alexander and
therefore they had to find various ways
to legitimize themselves in the eyes of
their populations and they did this in
various and very interesting ways
one of the ways that Alexander's
successors legitimize themselves in the
eyes of their populations was by having
themselves portrayed as physically
resembling Alexander so if you look at
their portraits whether they're in
statues or whether they're on coins for
example you see that often they are
depicted as having many of the same
characteristics and features as
Alexander's so they somewhat resemble
Alexander of course none of them would
have actually resembled Alexander
because they weren't related to
Alexander by blood but remember that in
antiquity there really was no mass
immediate communication as there is
today and usually most people never saw
the king in real life so the only way
that they knew what the King looked like
would be from an occasional statue that
was set up or perhaps those little coins
that circulated and had the portrait of
the King on him and so if they saw these
these images of the king and the King
looked like Alexander then the King
actually didn't need to say that he was
related to Alexander people would have
drawn their own conclusions so this was
one device for legitimizing themselves
these Kings legitimizing themselves as
Alexander's successors
another way that these that these
generals establish their legitimacy as
Alexander's successors was to imitate
what Alexander had done so they actually
did like Alexander and specifically what
they did was to found Greek cities just
as Alexander had established a city on
the coast of Egypt and named it after
himself Alexandria
so his successors founded new cities
around their kingdoms which they named
after themselves and these were not just
any cities they were specifically Greek
cities what's called a polis these
cities were Greek in that they had Greek
style institutions so for example
theaters for the performance of Greek
plays temples dedicated to Greek gods
council houses for Greek style council
meetings gimnasio so that the youth
could be educated in the Greek manner
and the the reason that they did this
was not just to imitate Alexander but
because these successors of Alexander
used Greek culture as a means of
unifying the diverse populations under
their rule and these populations then
who lived in these cities also grew
loyal to the king because they benefited
from living in a city that had all of
these wonderful institutions so this was
a very effective tool and it is what we
call a a process of hellenization the
making of these empires or kingdoms as
Greek the spreading of Hellenistic
culture or Greek culture throughout the
the realms ruled by Alexander successors
now what I would like to do is to
consider the possible parallels in later
traditions about Alexander the Great and
Jesus Christ these parallels have been
explored by a scholar named Oreo meet I
in a book called from Alexander to Jesus
that was published in 2010 and in this
book I meet I explores the ways in which
Alexander might have served as a model
for the mythical Jesus and noticed the
very important qualification here what
ami Tai is talking about is not the
historical Jesus but the mythical Jesus
by which he means the traditions that
developed about Jesus after his death
on me ties main points are can be sort
of summarized as follows as heir to the
Royal or GAD family Alexander was
conceived as a direct descendant of the
Greek hero
Heracles or Hercules and this was very
common by the way in the Greek and Roman
world that royal families would trace
their ancestry back to a hero or a god
and in this case Alexander's family
traced its ancestry back to the Greek
hero
Heracles or Hercules and Alexander
therefore is often shown in ancient
depictions with the attributes
characteristic of Heracles for example
sometimes he's shown as wearing the
lion's mane cape that you often see
Heraclius wearing omni tie argues that
alexander lived his entire life in
emulation competition and self
identification with Heracles this
established a basis for Alexander's
transformation from human to divine
which was not a feature of the Greek
world before then
now this is before we go on a an
important point because in the Greek
world before the time of Alexander Greek
rulers were not worshipped or identified
as gods as deities this was a
characteristic of the ancient Near East
if you think for example of the Egyptian
pharaohs but in the Greek world until
the time of Alexander rulers were always
very human and they were treated as very
human so one of the new features that we
see introduced into the Greek world
beginning with the time of Alexander is
this idea that the ruler becomes a God
is worshipped as a god this is why by
the way this tradition about the oasis
at sea WA where the priests of the local
or regular shrine of Zeus Emin come out
and Greek greet Alexander as if he's a
god that's the significance of that
tradition so on me ty here is pointing
out the importance of the the claim that
Alexander's family traced their lineage
back to Heracles the importance of this
in Alexander's perceived deification
that is that Alexander becomes a god so
he was descended already from gods and
therefore he himself becomes worshipped
as a God this being new in Greek culture
in addition I meet I points out
Alexander's legacy adopted a number of
motifs from the mythology of Heracles so
not only do we have this sort of divine
Antron seseri going back to Heracles but
there are other aspects of the mythology
of Heracles that become features of
traditions surrounding Alexander
including divine sonship double
paternity a world mission on behalf of
humanity and divinization
now interestingly these motifs are also
a part of the myth of Jesus not the
historical Jesus but the myths that
develop about Jesus
Alexander is a key figure here because
Alexander already was a key figure in
Jewish eschatological thought by
eschatological thought I mean traditions
or expectations among Jews about what
was going to happen at the end of days
in Jewish eschatological thought
Alexander is situated at the beginning
of a new era which is perceived as the
last stage of history before the end of
days the eschaton so in other words
Alexander in in Jewish eschatological
thought becomes connected with
expectations about the end of days and
specifically is thought as being placed
in a in a very key position in an era
right before the end of days is about to
begin
so in other words in Second Temple
period and rabbinic period Judaism
Alexander was understood as a necessary
step on the road to the advent of the
Messiah
now we have already seen that Alexander
plays a key role in the most influential
piece of apocalyptic literature produced
by Second Temple period Judaism
The Book of Daniel according to this
book Daniel stands in the royal court of
three successive kingdoms Babylon which
is symbolized by gold media by silver
and Persia by bronze and he looks into
the future where he sees the progress of
human history in a series of distinct
visions presented as a succession of
kingdoms
the last Kingdom the fourth Kingdom is
Macedonia symbolized by iron and this
kingdom significantly is to be followed
by God's kingdom
thus the Hellenistic age inaugurated by
Alexander is perceived as the last stage
in history before the dawn of God's
kingdom
the perception of Alexander as the
instigator of the last stage in history
before the messianic era based on his
role in the Book of Daniel was to become
a staple in Jewish eschatology in Jewish
traditions about the end of days
Josephus's story about Alexander and the
high priest which we looked at
legitimizes Alexander and his campaign
by making them part of God's plan as
foretold in Daniel so we can see the
influence of the Book of Daniel on later
Jewish writers and later Jewish
traditions now one of the questions that
ami ty asks is how was it possible for
monotheistic mythology to give birth to
a son of God so we would not expect
monotheists like the Jews this is what
Amita argues - to originate a belief in
a son of God where does this come from
and he proposes actually that Alexander
is the key figure here specifically ami
ty proposes that Alexander's historical
role as the paragon of divinization
combined with his positive reception in
wide circles within the Jewish world and
his pen ultimate position in
contemporary eschatology that he's
placed right before the beginning of the
end of days helped prepare the way for
the acceptance of by Jews of the divine
sonship principle this idea that the son
becomes divine
amita notes also the parallels between
Heracles and Jesus divine sonship double
paternity transition from the human to
the divine but only Alexander not here
Ackley's only Alexander was a
flesh-and-blood person who broke the
barrier between humanity and the divine
now Alexander died at the age of 33 and
another well-known parallel between
Alexander and Jesus is that it seems
that Jesus died also at the age of 33 at
least if we go according to the Gospel
accounts according to Luke chapter 3
verse 23 quote Jesus was about thirty
years old when he began his work end of
quote
which means that Jesus died at the age
of 33 based on John's reference to Jesus
celebrating three Passover's during his
ministry
other parallels between Alexander and
Jesus as we have seen include divine
sonship dual paternity virgin birth
world rule mission of the benefit of
humankind death at a young age before
the mission is complete and divinization
the myth of Jesus signifies the
acceptance of alexander's precedent of
divinization by believers in a
monotheistic faith
so ami ty concludes that Alexander was a
bridge between the worlds of monotheism
and polytheism and I quote Alexander and
Jesus were close neighbors in the
boiling matrix of gods
heroes and demons which characterized
the religious life of later antiquity
end of quote and so we conclude with
possible parallels between later
traditions surrounding Alexander the
Great in Jewish eschatological thought
and traditions and the mythology of
Jesus and his life